There is a democratic debate tonight on NBC
and MSNBC.
It's a partnership debate with the Nevada
independent.
This is just a few days before the third primary
of 2020 which is the Nevada caucus on Saturday.
Now as far as who will be participating, remember
that we speculated the DNC might do this and
they did at the end of January.
The DNC said we have no more individual donor
requirement to qualify for the debates.
This was very obviously a change that had
the potential to allow Michael Bloomberg into
the debates and it has worked to allow Michael
Bloomberg into the debates.
I told you yesterday that because of Michael
Bloomberg being in second place nationally
in the latest NPR, PBS, Maris, Paul, Michael
Bloomberg has qualified for tonight's debate
and very quickly the narrative is becoming
Bernie versus Bloomberg, the anti billionaire
or billionaire as Bernie likes to say against
the Uber billionaire because Michael Bloomberg
far wealthier than Tom Stier, far wealthier
than Donald Trump.
Now, very often the narratives that we are
told about the stories we are told about these
debates are completely fake and fabricated.
I remember that.
I think it was between the first and second
democratic debate where we still had like
12 people on the stage, somebody, some networks,
CNN or whoever was running that second debate
promoted tonight.
Beto versus booted, judge or whatever, you
know, some fake story that no one actually
cared about tonight.
The implications are actually huge in terms
of who goes up against whom, what sort of,
uh, uh, battles and enclaves and cliques start
to develop because there's a few possibilities
for tonight.
Does tonight become a, with Bernie as now
the leader in just about every recent poll
and Michael Bloomberg at his first debate,
does tonight become Bernie versus Bloomberg
with debates of out about billionaires and
fairness and stop and frisk or whatever else?
Is that the primary story tonight or does
tonight become everybody gangs up on Bernie?
In other words, the establishment candidate,
it's Biden boot edge, edge Klobuchar maybe
even Bloomberg.
Do they all gang up on Bernie to try to hurt
him or do the establishment centrists recognize
that the greatest threat to them is actually
the introduction of Bloomberg and maybe the
DNC saying Biden's crashing.
We don't want Peter, Amy, let's go with Michael
Bloomberg.
So do the establishment centrists tonight.
Not go after Bernie, but instead focus on
Michael Bloomberg.
We don't know the participants tonight.
Our Pete Buddha, judge, Bernie Sanders, Elizabeth
Warren, Amy Klobuchar, Joe Biden, and Michael
Bloomberg.
Uh, so we will see, uh, what dynamics develop
there and it could go a few different ways.
And in fact, if Michael Bloomberg continues
to gain polling support, the DNC is going
to have to make a decision.
Will the DNC see Bloomberg as a possible savior
from the declining Biden and an Amy Klobuchar
who has some support but doesn't seem like
really enough to get the nomination and to
boot edge edge?
Who while he did well in Iowa and New Hampshire
lacks experience, what is the DNC going to
do?
So will the DNC shift from Biden to somebody
else?
And if so, who will they shift to?
Again, Bloomberg in second place nationally.
Now in some polls, a third in an average of
recent polls, what is his future going to
be after?
Presumably winning some delegates on super
Tuesday and meanwhile if you are the establishment,
do you go all in on Bloomberg or ignore him
altogether?
That is a really significant decision that
the DNC establishment needs to make because
it's going to set the tone for whatever strategy
they are going to employ to try to deny Bernie
the nomination between now and the convention.
Remember Tom Stier is a billionaire, but far
less wealthy than Bloomberg, far less prominent
than Bloomberg.
Never really polling much at all with Bloomberg.
Now in the picture, we have the possibility
of Bernie and Bloomberg squaring off on exactly
the policies that Bernie would push, which
would cost Michael Bloomberg a lot of money.
Well, anybody call Michael Bloomberg out,
by the way, regarding the recent audio publicized
of Bloomberg saying horrible things about
black men and stop and frisk, or is that going
to be ignored in tonight's debate?
Will there be a question about that from the
moderators?
Bernie said at his rally Monday night that
Bloomberg will not be allowed to buy this
election and it would be very interesting
to see that confrontation and that topic come
up firsthand.
I hope you will join me live for a debate
pre-show starting probably around 8:15 PM
Eastern time.
Tonight we'll do about 45 minutes of pre show.
At the top of the hour, we will go to live
debate coverage.
We will be on YouTube and Twitch for the pre-show
debate itself, probably just on Twitch and
then back on both YouTube and Twitch for the
post debate analysis.
Join me there.
Let me know what you expect in tonight's debate
via Twitter.
I'm on Twitter at D Pacman.
Follow me
and let me know what you're expecting and
like debate